well good morning everybody for those of
you who don't know me my name is deb
woodcock and i'm the program manager for
the d mice informatics discovery lab
fondly known as the idl i wanted to make
a few housekeeping announcements before
we get started we are recording the
session so at the end or whenever you
ask a question i don't know what your
preference will be as far as whether you
want people to interrupt or wait to the
end please push down the button uh on
the speaker there and just hold it while
you're speaking and that will capture
capture what you're saying
um also we're streaming the talk live
today so if you're out there in the
twitter sphere and want to participate
in the conversation
please send a tweet to ohsu informatics
all one word and use the hashtag
dmeisconf d-m-i-c-e-c-o-n-f
today i have the great privilege
of introducing dr martha driesnak
dr giznak is an associate professor in
the school of nursing here at ohsu and i
had the good fortune to
be in an interprofessional education
class with her last fall called
narrative and healing which was true
really really wonderful class
dr dezak received a bs from the ohio
state university her ms from yale and
her ph.d from good old ohsu
following that she did postdoctoral
research fellowship in clinical genetics
at the university of iowa and the
national institutes of health
she's well known for her research with
children and her emphasis on engaging
children early and often in health
related decision-making using
child-centered and directed approaches
to data collection
one such approach is the integration of
children's drawings called the draw and
tell conversation or the dtc
um today dr dre snack will give an
overview of her work and describe uh the
some of the informatics challenges that
it poses you probably wondered a little
bit when you saw the title how this
related informatics and we'll make that
connection for you and then at the end
we'll also spend a little bit of time uh
talking briefly about this year's emia
student design challenge and uh the
reason we're tying this together is that
dr dre snacks presentation um
we're thinking of using as one of the
challenges that we we enter in this
competition uh there may be others but
we can talk about that later so without
further ado
dr grieza thanks um and you can
interrupt me anytime push your buttons
or just raise your hand you push your
button on your own i don't know anything
about that
oh that's what it is okay so whenever
you you can interrupt spontaneously
you know any time but remember to push
your button to speak so that they catch
the
so what i'm going to talk about is just
really a little bit about what deb said
is about my use of drawings and give you
a little bit of background and then the
challenge that i came actually down with
in terms of i have this
line where i say and then they just
upload this into the electronic health
record and i said devon then a miracle
occurs and so could you help me with
that miracle so that's really the
backdrop to this so i always start by
acknowledging the drawings that i will
show you some drawings from children and
they i do have permission from the
children to share that i don't share
drawings that they haven't given me
permission to do
so just uh as a just a little bit of an
introduction there's this whole emphasis
right now in patient-centered care and i
think one of the challenges is is around
how do we integrate that patient's voice
into care but it's even more challenging
when that patient is a child
children have primarily been seen
through adult eyes so when we think of
what we know about children today in
research it is typically from adult
proxy
it's not from the children themselves it
could be from parents teachers will
default right away and a lot of that is
because we when we ask children
you know to tell us something we use the
tools that are not appropriate for them
but i'll get into that in a second
because we use adult the reason we defer
to adults a lot of the time is because
we think of children as in the process
of being developing you know if many of
you have taken a developmental site
course you may have heard of piaget or
vygotsky or whatever what we're looking
at all the time is children are in the
process of becoming adults because of
that we think of them as human becomings
rather than as human beings so we figure
we can't really get any good information
from them until they can talk to us like
we talk
so there's this kind of like
developmental
lens that we see them through
and because of this all the tools that
we have
are really not child-centered in instead
they are adults so the tools that we
have even in research or in practice
are all adult developed they were
developed with adults and then what we
do is we think oh we'll use them now
with kids and we'll just put simple
language with them or we'll add a little
picture to it but what we don't realize
is just even adding pictures to things
it may make it child friendly but it
does not make it child appropriate
because children don't know seriation
skills in other words a rating scale one
to five where you say what you tell me
this and this is the well-known pain
scale tell me is this the worst pain
you've ever had and children will give
you all the way to the end yes it is
because it may well be the worst pain
they ever had and we instead look at
that and think they have no idea this is
not pain you know or this will discount
what they say so they don't know how to
put things in order yet about worse they
can only think in three categories up to
about the age of 10. so anytime we use a
sliding scale
of of greater than that children will
end up going to one end or the other
and and never writing in the middle so
they don't have that seriation skill the
other thing is when you look at this
this requires the skill of empathetic
recognition in other words you have to
be able to look at somebody else and say
oh that's what i look like when i'm
feeling painful and children don't have
that skill until they're about 10 years
old
fully developed so we're using tools and
i'm going to come back to this paint
because it's a lot of what i do
that are inappropriate for children and
and they get even better because you
know when you show these this is the
outer scale when you show these to kids
and if you look closely at these
pictures the kids will say i don't want
what's going on with those kids
you know they're like what is that and
even worse if we try to use in a
the adult skill they'll think oh get rid
of what's the matter with that man over
there that's not me i can't do that and
they'll immediately like to be replaced
they'll tell me when i have this content
expert panel when people do expert
panels they always have people in the
field i have a content expert panel that
is all kids
so they rotate through and they'll show
them a tool and they'll say oh get rid
of that drawing you know because that's
creepy and i said well it's very
appropriate of course for adults because
you've got all the dermatol you know
everything's all separated out and we
can quantify it but for a child they're
not going to fill it out and especially
kids with headaches would never have
filled it out because they don't like
the oversized head
so right now
part of the impetus for this talk or
paying a little bit more of attention to
kids is there is a current nih
initiative called
no more hand-me-down research now mind
you it's it's um
the energy behind it is coming from
medications like in other words most of
the medications we have for children
have never been tested with children and
so they're trying to engage children in
research get people to get children and
they now require us to have children in
research and you have to make a pretty
good reason not to have children in
research especially if you're developing
something that's going to affect them
the problem is they are working really
hard to do this and people are actually
engaging children in the research but
they're still using these tools that are
not appropriate so most of the tools
that we have for children have not
caught up to this invitation to include
children
so there's this movement now toward the
development of what we call child
sensitive tools
all right so these are child directed
tools this is where you shift the power
from the adult to the child and you get
the child you capitalize on the child's
cognitive
and behavioral strength rather than
adults
and
and what we have found is that when we
do do this we not only get more
information but the information we get
from kids is very actionable and helpful
and one of the examples is drawing
all you have to do is ask a child to
draw if i went into a kindergarten class
right now and i said who here
is an artist
everybody in the class would raise their
hand now if i ask you you probably have
been having beaten out of you if you're
an artist or not and usually that
happens by about the fifth grade
but under that time in those seven to
ten year old age range where they don't
quite have the verbal
capability they are still organizing all
their thoughts using sensory cues
rather than semantic or word cues so
they're in that development and you
started that way too
so even to this day a certain smell or a
scent or a feeling will take you right
back to a place that you had that goes
back to this time so this is their
strength right now so when you ask a
child to draw it gives them a moment
sort of a parallel space for them to
organize their thoughts before they talk
to you are you with me so far okay you
guys are all very
i'm used to kids like fidgeting and so
many things
okay and
yeah feel free to fidget past notes you
know those type of things but i often
interrupt and take the notes and read
them aloud
but anyway the the highlight the caution
i like to say right up front is that
children's interpretations are different
so just asking the drawing and taking
the drawing from the child is still
is not appropriate you have to get their
explanation the drawing is there for
them
it's not for you to interpret as much
but it's there as a prompt for them
and it you know you can look at it it
will affect you some of the drawings but
just know that the interpretations are
different and i often use this drawing
which is from the book the little prince
and it's just a great drawing but it's
it's probably the story of a little boy
if you don't know it
who is a prince
of a planet his whole planet or whatever
i always say it's every child's story
because every child is
king of their own domain if you're not a
parent you will find that out soon
enough um but uh what happens is he goes
to adults a series of adults with this
drawing and he says i have a really
big problem
and they are like that's a very pretty
hat go away or like you know go away and
they've interpreted this drawing as
something but if you look closely
there's actually an eye here at the end
of this
and really what this is
is a boa constrictor that has swallowed
an elephant
head first or and and both of them are
still alive and they don't know what to
do now this is not a real problem and
you're saying
like this is what happens with children
it's sort of fantasy but what it is
is a child coming to an adult with a
problem and asking for help and they are
pushed aside because we didn't take the
time to understand from their
perspective what that dilemma was so
does that are you sort of with me on
that so it's it's often what i use that
there are whole books about this and
people quote from this book all the time
but i love to show this drawing for that
reason
in real life it's the same thing so i
caution that i'm going to tell you the
use of the drawing but the drawing will
actually affect you but at the same time
you will interpret the drawing you'll
look at it and you'll say like you look
at this what do you think is going on
here
but i know that's wrong
yeah but but that's what i think it's
like you know yeah you sort of notice
the the eyes what do those eyes sort of
tell you
dizziness or get focused really in and
notice the blood coming out of the mouth
you know that could be the vampire the
teeth or whatever typically it's a
pretty angry
you know look to it and uh and the story
of this is i actually found this at the
airport all while balled up in a in a
wad and i was sitting at the airport
with my kids
and i opened this wad of paper up and i
think oh look at this
and it was right after columbine
and i'm thinking oh angry and all of a
sudden and my kids are like mom don't
don't look around don't do anything you
know this is not you're not in practice
right now they're like we're going to
washington right now and i'm thinking
and often i hear this patrick come over
here and i think he's patrick
you see patrick and i think it's patrick
so i'm like
you know so i just go over and i said
and he goes i said oh i found this he
goes oh yeah that's my drawing
and um and i said well
as usual you take this sort of stance of
not knowing what it is and i just
couldn't help myself and so and and he
said oh yeah i don't need that anymore
and i said why is that and he said
because i already lost my tooth
so do you know that feeling right before
your tooth comes out where it was
hanging
take yourself back to you know like in
that one moment at the and that really
actually captures it but how quickly we
can misinterpret something if we don't
take the time to listen to the child's
drawing
so there he is
so i offer every child the opportunity
to draw especially kids between the ages
of about five to ten in particular
and after that children tend to
sort of say they can't draw or it's like
an adult response and we do other art
projects and stuff with them too so art
in any capacity is helpful but i'm just
going to focus on the drawing today what
i like to say it's no child left without
crayons and then i make sure that i
listen to their story
but at the same time i recognize what my
response to it was so you have to
recognize that
check it and go wrong
so sometimes this is i did a lot of work
with the kids this is after 9 11 so
these are the twin towers and this is
just one of the drawings so we're part
of the children's television network a
long time ago so we would come in if
there's a big trauma we did it with the
hurricanes and the tsunamis and stuff
and it's a well-known way to help
children but this is a drawing that
everybody was going to use and put on
the front of the new york times they
thought it was so interesting that the
two buildings were crying until you
heard the child story and this is one of
the kids who was actually in the
elementary school
where they watched the people jump out
of the building for a long time before
the teacher finally got
herself together and i don't blame her
at all because i think it was probably
shocking to watch people to jump out and
then they finally closed the blind but
if you notice this
building is crying but what it is crying
is people see them down here
so they said in terms of so they ended
up once they heard the story of the
child and the child did not give them
permission to do it and they honored
that so you can do it in very dramatic
things or like i love to show this
drawing because it's like everybody
cringes when they see it and i think
i've drew this out for you guys
so this is a child and
i got called down to the emergency room
and said
this is a kid with trauma
abdominal trauma chronic abdominal pain
but had some other things going on with
them and they said they asked the child
because they knew i was coming they said
we have to draw a picture of what it was
that could you draw a picture of what
caused your pain or whatever and this is
what they grew and everybody had a heart
attack they were like oh my gosh we
didn't know or whatever they're going
through this whole thing and i looked at
this drawing i said you know this i know
what you guys are thinking but this
detail right here
is bizarre
nobody would spontaneously a child is
not going to draw the rave going up the
middle of the you know and i'm thinking
what the heck is that for somebody
walking in right now this drawing is
going to think what is going on maybe
i'm in the wrong talk
but anyway so when you ask the child i
just said could you tell me what this is
and the child said yes those are my
scissors i was using the wrong scissors
and if you look at it it's exactly what
it looks like but again it's this
caution about getting the story with the
drawing that the drawing is the
facilitator and the drawings can be very
complicated so you might look at this
this is a child with chronic pain
abdominal pain missing school and we're
trying to figure out what the heck this
was so i said could you draw a picture
of yourself and this is what they do and
i thought what am i getting now you know
it's got king of the jews on top of it
it has every detail if you know the
christian story this is jesus on the
cross with the nails and the details and
the slit on the side you know it was
really detailed but if you notice one
thing in particular this jesus
i didn't notice right away it has a
little bit of justiness and this was the
child who had gynecomastia and was
really suffering with that and this is
his only image of suffering that he knew
and then his way of telling so he was
just talking about so it can get
complicated and it can take you in a
totally different direction everybody
was working these kids up for first
spring and everything else with chronic
abdominal pain
here's another chronic abdominal pain so
you just draw a picture of yourself and
this was a drying so you can tell that
in my office we have pains and it can be
elaborate but you don't need to have all
of that and this is just a child whose
parents had recently divorced and he's
in two houses two separate and that's
what he ends up doing and they can be
really
so here chronic abdominal pain and you
look at it and what might you think is
going on here
fell down the stairs and maybe pushing
or something you know so the simplest of
drawing and actually this is a little
child who's trying to keep his
grandmother from going to heaven
so his grandmother's in the home and
she's dying and he doesn't want her to
die so he's staying home and creating
vape so i'm just going to give you a big
you know difference in terms of what you
can get you can get very specific so
those were three kids with chronic
abdominal pain here's kids with headache
pain so you just draw a picture of it
here it is pretty clear they've been
huge studies about how this is as good
as a lengthy neurology exam
you know that you can send this they did
hundreds of drawings to hundreds of
neurologists and they were able to
differentiate between migraine and
tension type headaches just on the
drawing in the child's story alone
you know that it's a it's a great
diagnostic tool and helps get the child
on the right track early on
so i started to do one study where we
had these varieties and then i contacted
my about pain we were looking in
particular about kids with chronic
headache pain there's a whole emphasis
on why we were doing that but then i
told
i was i ran this vibe this group of
expert panel and they said you know
there's an app for that
you know what's this piece of paper
drawing we'll draw right on our phone
for you or right on our ipads and they
have their ipads with this little hand
glove on the other side that they just
show you you know i don't know it's very
so and they said you should be using the
computer and so i switched then i
started to do headache drawings with the
computer and to draw a picture and of
course i'm telling them you know you can
make this bigger and enlarge it and draw
this in detail and smaller you can put
it in the whole context of the body and
they're like yeah we know that lady
you know that and i said it's called a
pinch mechanism and they're like
whatever
you know so i'm like explaining this to
them and they're just very spontaneously
doing this so now i have kids drawing
on their computers on their ipads
you know they can do it on a piece of
paper or they can do it on the computer
and they can send it to me they can do a
screenshot of that and then they talk
about what it is could you describe this
for me and the drawings can be quite
simple so this is a child who draws the
headache and this is a pain what if i
went back to that one tool
and said here's a drawing could you
describe it and could you say is this a
pulsating the child would not have
answered that wouldn't have come up with
the word pulsating or a throbbing pain
they wouldn't come up with that term but
that's exactly what this child described
that this is one point in their head and
this is what happened so this is the
point all blown up and it's big it goes
boom boom boom boom boom smaller than
big so
so it's a very clear drawing i can take
that drawing and then put it into my
characteristic terminology but i could
never have got a child to circle that
word at least at this age
are you with me still
you've got those are pretty flat okay
all right so here's another you can just
see with the computer so this is a free
drawing by kids where they blow it up so
here's the drawing on the left hand side
and then i have zoomed in where they
have zoomed out on the head
and this is where they describe their
headache as tectonic plates
unlike tectonic plates they go yes two
tectonic plates rubbing together and you
know what happens right before when the
whole thing explodes and i'm thinking
okay this is like this pressure sort of
and then what's really funny is when i
was doing this part of research say
there's this lightning over here the
parent was just outside the room because
the children are given the choice
whether their parents stay in the room
or go outside they all send the parent
outside it's sort of funny
and they usually say and let me know if
you need to go to the bathroom
it's a control thing but anyway
the mother was outside the door and said
tell them it's like a lightning strike
that was the mother's term and so he
dutifully drew the lightning bolt and
then went back to his tectonic plate
so that's there over on the side and
then down here in the stomach here this
is blown up he said it's like boiling
water and that's what that is like
you know the boiling water and you can
sort of feel that sort of hard hot or
whatever
sense that they have so their
descriptions are very good but they
would not have been able to use our
words to do it
and this is just another example and i'm
trying to emphasize how easy the drawing
is how simple the drawing is but how
rich the story then can be and this
you can see exactly where the headache
is that can be blown up and it was all
arrows pointing in and then in the
stomach it's like you drew a knot in the
stomach it's like there's a knot right
in the stomach so it was a great
terminology and here's the most simplest
drawing of all where they drew it out
and then you see this whole this little
arrow down here this is his stomach and
what he's describing here is that when
this comes
i always know it's coming because down
here first i get this thing that's going
to come up and shoot out of my mouth and
it starts here and then goes to my head
and then when it gets to my head then i
line so it's like that aura beforehand
with a free nod so you get a whole
picture with very simple so the drawing
itself can be very simple but the story
that accompanies it is rich
and what's most interesting to me
is that when i show this drawing to the
child six months one year later they go
oh no this headache's different
so they know their own drawing really
well
you know as opposed so it's an easy it's
important for me
to keep that drawing and what they told
me i usually keep a summary of what they
told me and i have that readily
accessible to me in a hard copy
which is my challenge here to the
informatics people how can i get this
into the electronic health record so
that's really my challenge is that i use
these drawings all the time i want them
readily available especially with kids
with chronic pain or ongoing symptoms
i try to get pediatricians and nurse
practitioners in the outpatient area to
use this if a child is in a rural area
to describe something draw a picture of
it send it in from home these are the
kind of the things that i'm looking at
because for me a picture is totally
worth a thousand words but only if we
listen to that
so this is like what happens and this is
the age group that it works for and
oftentimes we look at this age group and
say
they're not going to be able to give us
anything we have to go to the parent but
we can get an enormous amount of
information that's very
comprehensive
and actionable for us and i think it
makes our diagnostic abilities and our
ability to put the patient at the center
that child at the center of their care
and engage in the care because when i
pull out their drawing the next time
they go oh yeah now this has changed
this has not changed or this and they're
very oriented to that
and they love seeing that you kept their
drawing and it's one way to engage them
so
my particular challenge
is and what i came looking for the
informatics folks for was i say when i'm
writing grants and i'm trying to get
these things funded some of the research
or this is an intervention i say
and then you can upload these pictures
directly into the electronic health
record
and that's when i turned to deb and said
that's when the miracle occurs how can
you upload this
and make it readily available to me in
the clinic like when i'm seeing the
patient or on the floor how can a child
from home so i need it could be a hard
copy drawing because i often will get a
kid to draw right on the examining table
if i have the examining table there that
you know the white paper that's there it
can draw right on that some children
will prefer real art paper if you want
them to be an artist so i always make
sure i have really good quality art
paper they do not like drawing on paper
that has lines
they're like you know what what is that
you know that's you're not really
serious about my drawing i like texture
to my paper you know so some choice and
good tools and i have this advisory
group who's told me exactly what that
should be no broken crayons that's that
nonsense there come now with roll up so
it's a eternal sharp point
you know you wouldn't use a sharp not
sharp point either come on that
pencil
so i'm thinking fair enough
so i have sort of a very simple art kit
with kids that i use but it could be a
hard copy it could be a digital copy it
could be on an ipad it could be on a
phone
different types of
tablets that they use whatever it is
that they have that they can draw on i
want to be able to capture that i want
to be able to upload it
into um in some you know whether it's
from home or in the clinic so somebody
sent that to me
sure
oh yeah um so you've already talked
about narrative and the importance of
context so i'll just ask you kind of a
list of different sort of requirements
here
the first one is would you prefer the
narrative to be embedded or viewable at
the same time as the image or would it
be acceptable to have the narrative as a
linked note of some kind
it could be linked but i don't want it
not to be there like another the
importance of it is that it has to be
there so it could be linked but the
danger of it just being linked giving
people the option to look at it would be
that they might interpret it themselves
i can tell you the child doesn't need
the link
you know you know for me it could be if
the picture's there it would be nice for
it to be available without the link
because i could say this is what you
drew the last time but then i would say
and this is what you said this is how
you described it
you know and most of the time the child
will say i don't need to know your words
i know exactly what was going on there
they'll know their own drawing
so um that probably doesn't exactly
answer that question
oh actually that's perfect and and sort
of a related question is whether you
would ever want to capture audio or have
them speak in their own voice
so when i do this in research i embed
camtasia into the into the computer and
i capture their voice entirely the
entire story that's a big file
is it totally necessary all the time i
don't think so i can actually pull a
couple and um and what i'm trying to do
is make this efficient for the clinician
for the researcher but mostly for the
clinician at that end
so that they would actually use it and
if you have this big file that you have
to stop and then listen to um it's nice
to be able to capture it in research i
always do that and then
you know summarize it so it's sort of
like being able to capture
i should say um the essence of that
narrative or the child's words or the
child's prescriptions
it's always interesting to me in
patient-centered care when we do soap
notes you probably have you all heard of
a soap note i remember what the s stands
for
so it's when we do subjective and we
have the subjective objective assessment
plan that's what they say
and the subjective is usually one line
if you're lucky a little thing in quote
has headache for two weeks or something
like that we give a lot more credence
and attention to the objective and the
assessment in the plan this is really to
beef up the subjective part from the
child's point of view
and
i don't know how it gets into the soap
note but it's that piece
to capture in their own words but not
the whole thing
you know camtasia right so it's i mean
we use it for
lectures and things like that but it's
really easy to embed
but it um would not be necessary i don't
think overall accepting from home maybe
if you were
recording something so
because what you don't want is the child
to be able to send this to you from home
without their story
you know um or they can send it to you
and they'd have to talk to you but there
must be
um like a company of sticky note or
something on that
drawing should never be in isolation
it's a real caution for me or
the real no no no to have a drawing by
itself
that huh
you have more on that list
not yet
so so yeah no no so this is really um
deb asked me what is it that you need
and i said when i actually stopped to
think about it what i need is ready
access at the point of care to this
drawing so that i could show it to a
child so and and for retrieval so i can
show it to them and going forward at the
next visit but also
easy upload if they did it right there
in the office you know or at the bedside
in the hospital so it's not i say clinic
outpatient or from home but this could
be a child who goes home from the
hospital too
and i give you examples of pain because
i just pulled out one thing you heard
that i have a background in clinical
genetics so i also use these drawings to
explain genetics we get into the whole
mendelian course harry potter helps me a
lot with that because the children will
just tell me do they have the magic
chain or don't they are they squibs are
they you know they they can explain you
know incomplete penetrance and you know
all sorts of things with harry potter so
i have a lot of help and and evidently
spongebob squarepants has also done a
little lecture once
i have not seen that one but you know so
i do body outlines children will tell me
about where they think their illness
comes from how things are inherited in
their family we do three generation
pedigrees doing this whole thing it's
really a tool that's wide open people
use it a lot with trauma i'm focusing
here on pain because we
we only have this one pain tool and it
really looks at it's really not an
appropriate age level tool and it only
looks at intensity it doesn't really
describe the pain
and my emphasis on pain is because
children who have chronic pain end up as
adults with chronic pain and that's a
huge impact it's a huge fight and maybe
if we paid more attention when they were
young and address their pain early they
wouldn't turn into those chronic
syndromes i don't know that but that's
part of my emphasis
okay so this is really what i'm looking
at the ability for kids to send it in
from home i mean it might be nice if
they were in the school nurse's office
and could describe it too and send it in
i had talked with deb at one point you
know how i can send something in
on my chart
you know does it come in through my
chart how does it get to my chart to the
you know or you know does everything
have to be uploaded into the record i
don't know we talked a little bit about
gee
um
the radiologists they get to look at
x-rays at home why couldn't we be
looking at children's drawings at home
or something is it as simple as that as
just you know an x-ray with it but you
know unfortunately when we send the
x-ray we usually don't have a little
narrative that goes with it at least
less i knew there wasn't something so
that's really um
what i was looking for and then
any questions that we have and then
there's one should i put that last slide
up or you want to talk about that
so and this is me by the way in case you
don't see the resemblance so the kids
often will draw me and just say this is
this is a much better picture of you
than you actually actually look
maybe you should put this out because
they don't like the drawing i have on
the website you should put this up
instead
you're looking better here and i'm
thinking thank you very much
you have to really have a center itself
when you deal with children yeah
yeah really interesting um are you know
one of the concerns that um
we hear from clinicians is
you know concerns about
overload of data from patients now i
granted this is not a massive amount of
data
but on the other hand i could see
situations where this maybe comes out of
the blue you know via
delivered asynchronously you know so not
when the child's right there
and a clinician not knowing what to do
with it i guess it gets a larger
question about
have you or has anyone done any work on
the validity of what these drawings mean
um
and um
you know how um
how clinicians should be expected to
react you know going back you know i
mean if you're sitting in your office
and some child had just uploaded that
scissors picture
and you weren't even seeing the patient
that day
just some of those sorts of issues so
that the picture should be solicited
number one by the you know like could
you like in other words if somebody says
uh contacts from home i can give an
example with the chronic abdominal pain
or something let's send the kids back
home again having another headache and
this one seems different or worse
and i would say could you have them draw
a picture and describe it to me that
would be something from home i'm not i
would not be looking for spontaneous
things coming from home they usually are
solicited as part of you know tell me
what that's like you know or if you're
saying a patient is you know writing in
insane saying something i will tell you
that the term validity you know is often
brought up with you know how valid are
these how valid are children's stories
how valid are the drawings the drawings
by themselves people have analyzed
drawings for years that research started
in the psychopathology literature and so
we're always looking for something in
them
i'm not the validity of the drawing
itself is not my like the drawing you
can see is not what i always think it is
so
very invalid if you're looking at my
interpretation i always say that the
drawing is there to facilitate
the telling of the story and it's used
as the background to the narrative in
the front
but that said there have been studies
that have done where they actually had
children draw and tell following an
event to see how valid
the things were and they were extremely
truthful like in other words they said
these are exactly the facts this is what
happened when they did it so they did
they did it most of that research has
been done in new zealand
and australia so they actually looked at
it so first they looked at oh look you
got so much more information and then
they said well more is not necessarily
better you know kids can go off on big
stories not that adults cannot do that
either but
we give adults a little bit more
legitimacy
and then they said well let's just see
if it's actually can they give us
truthful or valid information and
reliable over time
and they did do that with set things and
so that has been shown uh there's been
meta-analyses done on terms of amount of
information that comes so it's really
the drawing
is a challenge because it's nice for the
challenge the drawing to come with the
narrative but the drawing is a
facilitator to the narrative it's a
better way to get information from the
child so i wouldn't want a spontaneous
drawings coming in especially not that
scissors drawing that would just and you
know there is a caution about that but
usually it's a how do you do this so
that if you needed
information from the child on a symptom
you could have them drive
and then tell you about it instead we
asked parents now you could
ask the parent
to draw i mean to get it from the child
and then tell you that would be a
default for most clinicians because
we're more comfortable dealing with
adults but i can tell you any study
that has the adult
description of the symptom and the child
description of the symptoms the adults
and the child do not agree
and i often show that just the lightning
bolt versus this and it's it is
and what we do is we have deferred to
the adult description
of it because we think of them as more
legitimate
does that sort of address your question
okay but i don't know i mean i suppose
once you open it
you know and drawings you might get all
sorts of stuff coming in and then it's
like what do you do with this
um
yeah
first just to comment that what you're
asking for at least the ehrs i've worked
with you can do
you most ehrs that i've worked with have
the facility to scan in data
so you have to scan it in
you can do that
and when you scan in a document you put
a cover page on it saying here's what it
is
so that is
relatively easy to do the problem
i'm thinking about if i don't know how
to do it is
the voice
got the voice input just having
taken the time to listen to the voice
bill no i know it's taking the time
it's the fact the fact that you know if
i've got five minutes to prep
i'm not going to spend three minutes
listening to a kid talk i'm sorry
it's i probably should but i don't
no and and clinicians will say i don't
have time for this or most of them
they'll say i'm not an artist i don't
have time for this or whatever but you
know what happens is when you look at
time this really actually takes very
little time to ask a child to draw you
could be getting something else doing
something else
um but and then to listen to it the
explanations can go on but rarely do
they go on more than you know four
minutes but it is
a lot of time but we do listen to
patients
and so that this goes back to my you
know the challenge when the patient in
this patient-centered care
equation is a child you know that
patient then comes with parents and
unfortunately sometimes they come with
two three four parents you know each
with their own story
and that's the issue i think with the
consenting from home
because i
i have worked with stuff that's come
from home
and the parent basically directs what
goes in
at least we'd say and there would have
to be that oh you know can't the child
can't directly send in but again this is
an engagement of the child's family in
their care and and it would not be open
to everybody it's a it's a tool to use
purposely just like you wouldn't give
everybody a pain tool
you know unless you were trying to get
more information about that
well on the technology side first of all
i was thinking facts as well the catch
is when i see people scanning at least
in small clinics it's black and white
and what i'm getting from you is there's
a lot of richness in the color
uh maybe even size scale and texture
that there's that there's some nuance to
this that just scanning it as a document
may lose
so scanning
might have its challenges sure
photographs absolutely so bill the
the handheld
the kids told me they they downloaded an
app for me called genius scan
i'm just saying that just this is what
you need lady you know
scan this right here upload or whatever
and the nice thing about geniusscan is
that it adjusts it does the
cornerstoning so if you hold the camera
at an angle it can adjust it so it's
flat so it kind of gives you a chance to
keep the aspect ratio of the image even
if you take kind of a sloppy picture
so genius again is a great idea the
other part though
are these behavioral health records are
they clinical records is there a concern
where on the record they go and who can
see them yeah so you you always when
you're dealing with children could get a
drawing that has implications
equally in terms of child's maltreatment
you know or abuse neglect even when you
least expect it i could be doing a
headache study and all of a sudden
what i'm finding is that you know this
chronic headache there's an underlying
story so we have i always say in the
backdrop there's this little legal
caution about if you get something in a
story that has any suspicion of abuse or
whatever the um
place in the record for me is in the uh
depending where you are so if you're in
up on the unit and you're doing this at
the bedside it would be nice to have
that there and available to pull up for
the child to respond to in the future
like if they did some drawing on a
computer or a tablet and then you come
back two days later and you say is this
still what's going on can is something
else can you describe it add to the
drawing now give an update or whatever
that would just be as progress
think about it as where would you put
the patient's story with an adult it
would be the same thing i just don't
know how to embed
that drawing i i too thought can't we
just scan this in can't we just do this
like an x-ray or you know make it
available in a file or something um
it was like a little bit of a challenge
like where would that be how would you
access that or only who has that i think
it's like who has access then to this
and and who would draw it back up
it's like every informatics problem the
technology is the easy part the
challenging part is where
how to get it into the record you know
what metadata to associate with it and
so forth um
you know i mean i'm kind of joking you
know showing my phone around because you
could very easily take a picture of it
but but there's much more complex issues
than just the bits that you capture and
that and that's usually when i say i
just take a picture you know the kids
have i had to get an iphone uh because
they were disgusted
with my old phone they said put that
brick away i mean you know kind of thing
and but you know the idea is that just
take a picture of it and then they said
no you could do better with the scan so
they have that whole thing but you know
that's there where do i put it how
accessible it is and i always say oh
when i'm writing a grant or something i
just say and then it can get and here's
the great thing it's uploaded directly
into the electronic health record but i
know that that little one-liner comes
with this whole background and that's
really it sounds like a very simple
thing so part of my challenge is
actually getting people to do this
and see that it's easy and and that it's
informative to get people because people
dismiss
just like that little prince drawing
it's a it's easily dismissed and
children are easily invalidated for what
they say like i don't know how to but if
if they had this experience one thing
once they do it i don't think people
ever turn back it's just saying people
could try it that's one challenge the
other challenge is they'll say it takes
too much time or how complicated is this
or we've got enough problem with these
records already but if it could be at
the same time
integrated so that's
really um was my whole
you know challenge to that i can say
it's easy because i can say could you do
that
make this miracle happen so yes
so i'm interested in the narrative piece
and how much narrative is enough
to go into the record let's just say
that it's text in some in some way how
do you decide now how much narrative is
enough to put in
so um
when i've done this in research as i
said i've captured the whole narrative
the
with camtasia where it's embedded and i
get the whole story and it would be nice
to have the whole story just like you
have the patient's whole story
but as a clinician when i put on that
clinician's hat i'm constantly doing
that whether i deal with a parent adult
or a child i'm constantly
you know saying tell me your story
and then i write down what i took from
that story that big those bits and
pieces oftentimes what i'm trying to do
is this is how the child describes
something if i'm doing pain it's pretty
straightforward if i'm looking at
you know something more complicated
about their like an emotional experience
or their their fear or something it's a
little bit bigger chunk of that
but
most of the time i'm paraphrasing what
they have and i've saved the whole chunk
of what they have as a reference so it
would be great to have the whole story
you know what i mean the whole narrative
if i could capture the whole thing but
in reality it's not what people do i get
it for the purity of research i always
do that
uh and pull forward so you know if
anybody wanted to audit that or look or
if i go back and think oh i didn't think
about that before i didn't pull that
word forward i have the entire
transcript is that necessary for
practice i don't think so just like we
just
i could listen to your whole story about
headache and i would write down patient
describes you know throbbing unilateral
you know we have the terminology that we
use this
step for me is just getting the child to
give me in their own words so that i can
then put it in our speak
you know rather than asking the child to
participate in our speak
which is what we do now and the only
thing we have that's at least remotely
friendly for children is an intensity
scale which is totally inappropriate
it's far beyond their skill level and we
wonder why we don't i mean people say oh
yeah it works if you get if and the
children will tell you if you have kids
with chronic pain you have to answer
here if you want medicine
like that i don't know where to put it
but i've noticed that you have to do
this and they tell each other you have
to give at least a five here or six here
if you want to you know the school nurse
will only give you your medicine if you
do a six
so i mean they they've learned to work
around that tool i don't know that it
really cash and intensity is such a
small part
of pain
of the pain experience especially in
chronic pain because intensity kind of
goes out of the
thing so particularly looking at it
right now with chronic pain and chronic
symptoms
but you can do it with asthma asthma
we've done it with asthma symptoms
you know what happened here can you
visit
yes
um
i worked in a behavioral health study
for children once
and we had a paper chart but the paper
chart had a separate section
for we call it debriefs
where the child would either write or
draw
and would store that easily next debrief
and i could see
doing something similar for
at least where i work we could just set
up
literally if we had agreement through
practitioners we could set up a separate
section for that
yeah it's an interesting point because
at one point early on i had asked not
this group here but
when i was at iowa i came here from the
university of iowa i said can't we where
is the kids chart
you know where is this kids part of this
chart where we could have stuff in here
that the kids bring from home or
whatever like where is this child's
voice you know how do we get this voice
because there's in this patient's center
care
and i had said could we maybe have a
section and we were dealing with paper
charts at that particular point so you
had that i mean in my own charts when i
had my own practice you know there was a
section right in the front so the very
front you could see the drawing every
child coming in had to do a drawing and
they would come in where's my drawing
from last time you know or something
like you know they just came in looking
for it but um
and so right away are engaged in that
whole process that you're sort of
interested in so the two things they had
always for me is what book are you
reading and where's your picture and
they you know they learned that
especially in well child care and you
see that oh my headline today in
american academy of pediatrician says
children should be read to and i'm
thinking hello
you know that's been that we've known
that for you know that that research is
way old but it's so good that they're
doing it now that they've made that
mandate or you know suggested but that
was like in there and that was a section
right up front it wasn't a separate
section but i thought how do we make the
chart the child's chart you know child
friendly in that sense or sensitive to
the child's needs that's what
patient-centered care is it's engaging
the patient be patient in the care
and we are trying to become more
friendly to adults that way and we have
this whole thing but we have not quite
taken that step with children this is
just one piece so a section in the chart
might be good and might help
if people could access that who are
willing to access it i wouldn't call it
necessarily only behavioral and
developmental but i get that if it was a
particular study but a separate section
for the kids themselves that they could
access or that is accessible and again
readily accessible so
interesting yeah
so there's a big effort right now to
make charts accessible to patients uh
and it makes me wonder as a lab tech
what that means in terms of translating
into clinical ease to patient ease now
we're talking about children so the
question is is there a role for
a patient owned chart that's almost a
diary or a log that selectively shares
information with an electronic record
or are you thinking that the electronic
record should really serve both purposes
that it should look and feel usable
to patients children and elderly
included
those are great that i'm not thinking
any i'm only thinking that how do we do
this how do we engage children's voices
more in care that is around them and and
i find
when i had a paper chart i could do that
as we switch to the electronic health
record it's become
a challenge i just can't get my head
around where i put this in and have the
ease of access but i'm having trouble
ease of access with the electronic
health record sometimes getting other
things too so it's not just
that but the idea of a patient record
a parallel chart i mean i shouldn't use
that term because that's a narrative
term but um you know people you know
keeping a parallel chart i think
physicians and care providers right now
are trying to keep a parallel chart
themselves so you're going to have a
whole other group of people coming to
you as informatics people to say how can
i do a parallel chart you know of
writing my reaction to this patient that
doesn't belong exactly in the record but
i want to communicate to other people in
in essence that's the same challenge
you know
it would be a would be another challenge
but something to think about what other
people might want to do this i know the
opening of the chart
to patients is really
quite something because when you see a
lab report if you've ever seen one
sometimes it's like and my whole work in
genetics is about incidental findings
and so when you have an incidental
planning in a genetic study do you share
it or not share it is it clinically
applicable who are you to judge whether
it's applicable or not you know
especially if you find a
you've done a genetic screening like we
do on children right now with the
developmental delay
and we find a couple other things that
may be an adult onset disease or
something because we know and we know
beforehand we're going to find it
because now
we do a whole segment we're doing you
know we're doing excel testing i mean we
don't just look at one gene or one
little thing anymore it's like in the
past when you wanted to know a sodium
you could order a sodium but now if you
want a sodium you get a chem 23. so when
the patient looks at that they can say
well what's this over here this looks
and you're not paying any attention to
that it's not really
relevant to what you're doing and it
could be off a little bit you know but
the patient gets that information so we
have incidental findings
and
people have looked past it but i think
that whole parallel ethical decision
around opening charts is there
and who makes that judgment what
information is shared and not shared
and we do a lot of that what we call
paternalistic decision-making with
children
and even with their families and then we
have that parent somebody brought up and
it may have been you dan about the
parents and sending something from home
that is also
a challenge because the parent does have
to approve you you can't not i went into
pediatrics because i'm really not an
adult person i really like kids
you know unfortunately kids come with
adults i forgot that little piece you
know but the thing is uh and so but you
they are a gatekeeper and so you must
engage but i have yet to find a parent
who did not appreciate the engagement of
the child or to use this and and come
back to it or say later gosh i was way
off i never heard that because i always
said is it like a lightning bolt or
something is it like this because that's
their own experience
and so um
great um conversation yeah you know and
thank you dr dusak for coming and
spending time with us today you can tell
from the engagement of the group that
this is something that's got people
really thinking
and so i just wanted to touch in the
last few minutes that we have and just
make people aware they're interested
that amia for this this is their second
second year that they're sponsoring a
student design challenge
and this year it's titled beyond patient
portals engaging patients with their
health care providers
and um aaron i think had the had the
bright idea after having spoken with dr
grieznack a couple of times that
her uh her problem might be a good
challenge to try to tackle um for this
it's not the only problem that we would
have to tackle but what i'm in the
process of doing is gathering names of
folks who might be interested either
faculty advisors or
students who might be interested in
participating in this challenge and
putting together a team specifically to
address her problem
can i recommend um bringing this to judy
as part of our interoperability class as
maybe either a case study or as
you know some course content that might
bring out some students
what you call that interoperability
interoperability because on the again i
bill is exactly right this isn't just a
technology problem but getting something
from an iphone into an electronic a
health record is what that class is kind
of about not just hospital hospital lab
i just never heard the name of that that
course so it's a great title
it's desperately needed primary care
interoperability sounds much more
engaging i might have to take that
oh really since this summer
sorry
late summer
andrea do you know
are you pushing your button
right
it's an it's an expanded an extended
abstract yeah
so as you can see the abstract is uh
describes the challenge a proposed
solution and the design process so
there's a lot of work that needs to
happen between now and and august 1st
and then you can see the timeline um
eight will be selected to present
posters at amia and then four of those
will be selected to give presentations
or presentations at amia which is in
november
so uh if you're interested or you think
that there might be somebody who's
interested that you know
please feel free to refer them to me
they don't have to be here in portland
all you folks out there
we also have already somebody who's
interested who's in la we'll work the
team virtually as well as live
and we're going to hold an organizing
meeting next week on the 2nd so
just shoot me an email if you're
interested and i will add you to that
meeting and then we can talk about
this challenge as well as any others
that people would like to address and
figure out how we'll we'll proceed from
there it would be busy july
so you need to be willing to pitch in
during that pro that that month but
otherwise it would be i think it would
be a great experience
and we would maybe help you take a step
toward solving your
i problem vouch for that
thank you very much
you